this video is sponsored by a blue apron
hey wisecrack disembodied jared here
grab that potato chip and eat it
because we're talking about the anime
phenomenon death note
while death note addresses a range of
philosophical topics spanning from
property rights to human nature one of
the most interesting is
justice what is it and how should it be
applied
justice is hardly a new topic in media
so why is death note so
special well whereas most pop culture
gives us a cut and dry
idea of justice death note is unique not
in what it says about justice but how it
goes about saying it
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of death note
and even though this show is 10 years
old spoilers ahead
also a quick note about dubs versus subs
seems like no matter what we do we
somehow do it wrong
so we're just going to use the dubs on
this one because it's easier for us to
work with
hey that's more time for us to read and
write and make more episodes so
please don't hate us death note follows
light yagami as he discovers the
death note a notebook that can kill
anyone by writing their name in it and
picturing their face
light a model student wants to use the
death note to create a world devoid of
crime
soon after he adopts the public persona
of kira the god of the new world he
hopes to create
of course anonymously killing huge
swaths of criminals places him in
conflict with various law enforcement
agencies
a mysterious detective named l and his
two successors
nnm in death note we see multiple
characters exploring what is and
isn't justice let's just say the word
comes up a lot
i am just justice justice justice
justice
justice justice but the cool thing is
the show doesn't give us a clear stance
on what constitutes justice
but rather employs a unique method to
constantly
challenge various definitions of it an
element of that method happens in how
individual characters propose their own
version of justice and first among these
is light himself
it's hard to get a good sense of who
light was prior to the death note
although we have some clues to his moral
compass there must be something wrong
with me to even consider it
and his sense of moral obligation this
world is rotting
and those who are making it rot deserve
to die someone has to do it so why not
me
kira is an ends justify the means kind
of guy essentially the ends of being a
crime-zapping uber-tyrant justify
pretty much anything including
shamelessly using his girlfriend to
distract the police and maximize his
kill count
i wish i knew but i don't because if i
did i thank him for punishing the
burglar who killed my parents
to me cute as a hero and killing people
who aren't even criminals who get in his
way
however once light renounces ownership
of the notebook i hereby forfeit
ownership of this notebook
he loses his memories of being kira and
his personality changes noticeably
as does his sense of justice he goes
from being a by any means necessary kind
of dude
to a well maybe i shouldn't always be an
[ __ ] kind of dude
this is shown by his refusal to even use
mises feelings in order to get
information
to me exploiting another person's
feelings for personal gain is
unforgivable
and i won't allow myself to stoop that
low this is a huge
change from the guy who pretends to love
her for years just because it was
convenient for killing people
light is even told by misa that she
doesn't mind being used for his cause
i already told you i don't care even if
all you do is use me
you'd think that would be enough but he
always goes an extra step out of the way
to break his promises to her
here is a bit of a boy but light minus
the notebook
seems to respect misa at least enough
not to lead her on hey light
wanna come sleep with me tonight what
are you talking about
once he touches the death note again and
regains his memories and powers his kira
persona returns and he moves in with
misa almost immediately to get even more
bonus killing power
in other words treating people well is
thrown out the window
for justice with a capital j there are
countless examples of this tension
between light
pre and post notebook although they
merge more and more toward the end of
the show
one of the ways this is portrayed is
through light's conversations with
himself
where he grapples with moral and
practical dilemmas does that split
personality sound familiar well yes we
watch precious
both death note and lord of the rings
are likely descendants of an
ancient greek story called the ring of
gaijins essentially a guy finds a ring
that makes him invisible
and using this anonymity he immediately
bangs the king's wife
kills the king and takes over whatever
spooky greek magic town he lives in
we could probably read this as an
allegory for the perils of internet
comment sections
but i digress in plato's republic this
story raises a lot of questions about
the idea of justice the character
glaucon who was
actually plato's real life big brother
uses the fable to argue that justice
is just the kind of social contract that
keeps people from hurting each other
the thought experiment is meant to
demonstrate that people only really
value justice
for its ability to make them look good
in other words it's only natural that
someone with an invisibility ring would
go around acting like an asshat
because people only value justice or
morality when their actions can be
scrutinized
sound familiar humans will always try to
maintain appearances when they're in
public that's
just how we are but this is how they
really feel
most are too afraid to support me as
they're worried about what others will
think
many would rather deny my existence but
on the internet
where you can remain anonymous support
for kira is growing
as soon as the risk of damaging your
reputation is gone so is all your
interest
in justice glaucon goes on to say that
it doesn't matter if you were just or
unjust before putting
on the ring the power will inevitably
lead you to be a bag of dicks
and that's okay i can use the death note
all i want and i won't be punished
according to glaucon if you can secretly
bang the queen
and still keep your reputation you will
be way happier than someone who cares
about justice
and bangs zero queens and that's pretty
much light the golden boy valedictorian
who puts on a
show of normal morality even when he
takes joy in doing stuff that is
probably
way worse than breaking the royal bro
code i never once felt cursed since i
picked up the death note
in fact the thought never even crossed
my mind
i'm happier than i've ever been all
thanks to this power
i'm going to create a perfect world so
why do glaucon's musings matter here
because one of the key questions death
note asks is what does justice mean
when nobody's looking this theme is
repeated in light pseudonymity as kira
in lnn's namelessness and in the
anonymity of the cure supporters later
in the show
and here's where the republic really
comes in handy as a socratic dialogue
it's far less concerned with offering a
theory of justice than it is with
detailing the process
of exploring justice in it socrates and
his frenemies use hypothetical scenarios
and varying definitions to challenge
what
constitutes justice death note works in
a similar way
showing the movement and evolution of
theories of justice between
and within the characters many of the
characters in death note
misa light and mikami to name a few
believe that they possess
true knowledge of justice and the
tension between these characters and
their skeptics draw out the real meat of
the show
in one of the least subtle scenes both l
and light declare in unison
i am i am justice
this sentiment is repeated throughout
the series especially
in the final episode where light claims
that by reducing violent crime
and ending wars he has become justice
itself
kira has become law in the world we now
live
he's the one who's maintaining order
i have become justice and here death
note establishes itself as a kind
of modern socratic dialogue using
multiple participants to try and flesh
out some universal question
like what is justice a law the republic
from the minute light proposes his
vision of a new world in episode 1 i
want the world to know
of my existence that there's someone out
there passing righteous judgment on the
wicked
the question of justice is brought into
play while he does struggle with himself
for a second
who am i to pass judgment on others his
first real challenger is ryuk
light sets out his plan to immediately
kill off the worst criminals
while letting the lesser ones die off
then and only then the world will start
moving in the right direction
it'll be a new world free of injustice
and populated by people who i've judged
to be honest
kind and hardworking but if you did that
it would make you
the only bad person left ryuk is
motivated by boredom rather than any
sense of moral duty but he notices the
contradiction in light's argument
beginning the socratic dialogue that
lasts the rest of the show
there's no need to chronicle every
moment of this series-long philosophical
inquiry but there are definitely some
highlights that show us the trajectory
of this conversation
i've got a pretty good idea what your
motivation might be and i can guess what
you hope to achieve
however what you're doing right now
is evil you think i'm evil
i am justice if this wasn't clear enough
this is where they end the episode by
yelling i am
justice just to make sure we get it and
did we get it
yup right they both think they're
justice
light likes to refer to himself as a
martyr even if it means sacrificing my
own mind and soul it's worth it
which is pretty weird considering that
he spends years trying to make himself
the ruler of the entire world
but if you subscribe to his
quasi-utilitarian theory of justice
that killing criminals and making one
person god will ensure
peace and happiness for the greatest
number of people then he
is sacrificing himself knowing that
becoming the god of the new world
will mean becoming more and more kira
slowly killing
light yagami it also means that in
exchange for cleaning a rotten world he
would have to contend with a rotten self
something that he acknowledges kira
probably knows that what he's doing
is evil but he'll try to change the
world even as a martyr
at the cost of his soul that's his brand
of justice
so this is light's conception of justice
the world
needs akira and since he was chosen he's
willing to sacrifice himself in order to
make that happen
kira's idea of justice is an old
testament style bloodbath where sinners
get punished and blasphemy is the
biggest sin of
all did we mention the veritable monsoon
of biblical imagery in this show
you know the churchy coral music
[Applause]
this ode to michelangelo's the creation
of adam the apple's everywhere
l even washes light's feet since light
spends most of the show acting as kira
the distinction between the two may not
be terribly important but kira seems to
represent
light's ideal version of justice that
the only true
just world is one without criminals
achieved by whatever means necessary
however
l speaking as lind l taylor highlights
the contradictions in kira's reasoning
if a just world is one without
criminality then the criminal act of
killing people is
also an injustice this resembles ryuk's
rebuttal in episode 1
but the difference is that ryuk stops at
the suggestion that light might be bad
while l offers a competing example not
only is kira
unjust catching kira is itself an act of
justice
the show stops short of telling us what
l believes justice is
in order to believe that kira is
violating it but that's kind of how
socratic dialogues work
poking holes and raising questions to
get closer to the truth
kira imagines justice as a grand ideal a
world without criminals
l however only talks about justice as a
reaction to injustice
a lot of characters believe in light's
ideal justice but others seem to echo l
philosopher john rawls much like light
and plato
argues that in order to correct
injustices in society
we first need to have an idea of what
justice is
rawls and plato disagree on a lot but
they both support
ideal theory that when thinking about
justice we should first try to
understand what it would look like in a
perfect world where everyone did
exactly the right thing this is justice
under
ideal conditions which for light and
mikami
involve a lot of people being dead
however
others like philosopher naomi zak favor
something called
injustice theory this approach does not
rely on a pre-existing ideal of justice
and the perfect just society
but rather centers on identifying
injustices where they occur
it's much more practical to point to a
case of injustice than it is to start
from a broadly applicable definition of
what is just
by this measure only after injustice has
been identified
can justice be applied to correct it the
lmn
alphabet soup's hunt for kira doesn't
seem to be directed by a belief in a
high in the sky definition of justice
but rather by the recognition that
kira's new world
is unjust since we never get a clear
sense of what else concept of justice is
it seems totally plausible that he sees
justice as the response to
injustice so while light and those
similar to him favor a rawlsian approach
of a world created around a perfect
justice l is more focused on correcting
injustices as they appear
any definition of the just becomes
secondary
the struggle and resulting dialogue
between these beliefs
characterizes much of the philosophical
method in the show
although other characters like matsuda
complicate the conversation
and prevent it from being a split
between just two ideas
that being said we should briefly take a
second look at our cake snarfing
sherlock
holmes his code of justice is a bit more
ambiguous than lights
although its very ambiguity plays an
important role
in many cases it appears that l and n as
well as
m are most interested in winning a game
of wits that
game may be a symbolic battle between
competing moralities
or it could just be a case of some
narcissistic geniuses obsessed with
puzzles
in either case this lack of any strong
convictions about a positive meaning of
justice
serves at least one critical purpose it
means that elf frequently plays the role
of inquisitor
not so different from socrates in the
republic another somewhat more
surprising inquisitor is matsuda who
raises sincere questions about the moral
judgments of
light kira the japanese police hell just
about everyone
even at the same time as he is mocked
for his inability to fall into line
early in the season he responds to
elle's speech on the childish morality
of kira by pointing out that violent
crime in the area has decreased since
kira began
killing well i'm not saying this to
support kira or to condone the murders
but in the last few days throughout the
world
but especially here in japan we've
observed a dramatic decrease in the
number of violent crimes committed he
makes clear that he does not condone
kira's vision or actions
but he's also skeptical of the hard line
taken by l
later in the series he has an exchange
with the other members of the task force
that calls into question the very
foundation of the squad
the belief in the inherent evilness of
kira do you guys ever think that maybe
kira isn't completely evil
what what kind of question is that
matsuda i've been thinking about it
and part of me just doesn't believe that
he is so now you think kira is justice
too
i don't really know but i think that
kira's trying to fight evil and change
the world in his own way
and well the world's become a good place
for people who live honest lives so
matsuda with all his self-doubt is both
audience surrogate
and philosophical foil to the other
characters unlike
light who is convinced of his own
project l and n
who are single-mindedly obsessed with
the task of catching him
chief yagami who is focused on finding
the true kira
to clear his son's name and the rest of
the task force who have all staked their
lives and beliefs on the justice of
ending kira once and for all
matsuda is constantly questioning the
values that are presented to him
as fact hang on am i the only one who
sees something wrong
he can go around accusing people of
being kira but the fact that he's
wearing a mask
says he's only trying to protect himself
not anyone else matsuda's demeanor is
very different than the bravado of
plato's debate club boys but he first
and foremost recognizes his own
ignorance it is i mean no way which is
crucial for revealing the ignorance of
those around him
even at the end as he kills light he
does so with questions
rather than answers what was it all for
then
what about your dad what the hell did he
die for by forcing the viewers and other
characters to consider their own
opinions of justice
matsuda helps organize a jumble of
competing ideas
into a somewhat intelligible
conversation matsuda the modern socrates
as 10 years of fan forums demonstrate
there's no real consensus on who best
represented justice or whether light's
new world justified the means
but that ambiguity is what makes the
show so poignant
death note is an addicting detective
procedural but it never abandons the
original question of
what makes a just world and most
importantly
it never gives us an answer in episode
30 aptly named
justice light pretty much sums it up if
kira gets caught then that makes him
evil
but if he wins and rules the world then
i guess he's justice by the end of the
show
kira is defeated and ends brand of
justice seems to prevail
but it leaves us with a feeling that
things might have been very
different if kira had survived the
warehouse rather than giving us closure
that
l and n were innately more just than
kira this idea of winner gets all
morality
reveals that the war of competing moral
codes was kind of a logic
game not a kind of truth seeking you
could argue that this makes justice
totally meaningless
for the world inside the show and might
be justice
but for us the viewers it's not quite so
clear-cut
in regards to the meaning and
implications of justice death note opens
more doors than it closes
in terms of whether or not socrates or
rawls or zack would find
l or kira to be paragons of justice the
short answer is
definitely not although there are some
similarities that we didn't address in
this video
like themes of tyranny and a focus on
what it means to be a just city
the real connection between the justice
of the republic and justice in death
note
is not in their definitions but in their
methods
and that method distinguishes death note
as a show that does philosophy
rather than just borrowing it thanks for
watching guys
peace but before we go i want to share
something with you guys that i love as
much as philosophical anime and its
delicious free
food and blue apron has got me covered
on that if you're one of the first 150
wisecrack fans to sign up at the link in
the description below
it can be your next favorite thing too
blue apron is offering three meals free
on your first order for the first 150
wisecrack fans who sign up from this
video
just make sure you do it at the link in
the description below blue apron
delivers farm fresh ingredients that
look
and taste amazing and while i still only
have the cooking skills of a college
freshman our team had no problem
following the easy directions with all
the pre-measured ingredients to cook a
crazy good meal and as always ryan had a
lot of fun
smelling it all and this month blue
apron has more delicious meals on tap
including sauteed shrimp and green beans
and the delicious meatball pizza we
devoured
seriously guys it was good and so easy
if you love food and want an easy way to
cook
great meals at home check out blue apron
they deliver
fresh ingredients with delicious recipes
and it all comes in a refrigerated box
so ingredients stay fresh even if you're
not home when it arrives
shipping is always free and you can skip
or cancel service at any time so if
you're looking to expand your cooking
repertoire and hate going to the grocery
store as much as i do
or just love the idea of fresh
ingredients delivered to your door check
out blue apron at the link in the
description below
and remember get your free food now the
first 150 wisecrack fans to sign up with
that link
get three free meals on their first
order thanks to blue apron for
sponsoring this video
that's all for now i'm starting to get
hungry again surprise surprise
thanks and don't forget to subscribe
y'all peace